playstation and thq nordic have both
revealed the dates for their special
showcases this september minecraft live
is confirmed for october and destiny 2's
newest patch is bringing cross-platform
a voice chat to the game i'm persia and
this is today's gamespot news update
sony has announced a playstation
showcase for september 9th where it's
planning to talk about some upcoming
games as titles like horizon forbidden
west and more are coming out in 2022.
sony says that this event will be around
40 minutes in length and will begin at 1
pm pacific 4 pm eastern giving viewers a
glimpse into the future of the ps5
console and games releasing this holiday
and beyond fans can expect news from
playstation studios and industry
developers as well as a post-show
presentation for more updates from some
of the studio teams featured in the
event one part of the playstation
experience that won't be making an
appearance though is sony's next
generation of virtual reality
but there will be plenty of great ps5
games from developers large and small
according to the company
now that games such as return and
ratchet and clank rift apart have
launched sony's next big first party
games consist of february 2022's horizon
forbidden west and beyond that god of
war ragnarok final fantasy 16 and more
let me know which games you're hoping to
see during the showcase personally give
me more god of war
to celebrate its 10th anniversary thq
nordic is hosting a digital event on
september 17th at 12 p.m pacific and 3
p.m eastern with new information on open
world rpg e-likes 2 and more the
showcase will be hosted by the game
awards executive producer jeff keeley
and will feature six new game
announcements thq nordic didn't reveal
exactly all of the games that will be
featured during the event but it did
tease the return of a legendary
franchise that fans have been waiting
decades to get their hands on there'll
also be new footage for expeditions rome
the time splitters and metro franchises
are obviously two games that could be
the big return that thq nordic is
talking about but we won't know for sure
until the showcase
minecraft live will return in 2021
through a digital showcase that is
scheduled for the middle of october the
minecraft live event will celebrate all
things blocky promising an epic live
stream for fans to tune into you can
look forward to guest appearances by new
and familiar faces from developer mojing
studios the community at large and a
surprise appearance or two there will be
in-depth interviews exciting reveals and
lots of puns mojing said in its
announcement part two of the cliffs and
caves update is still on the way so i'm
excited to see if we're gonna hear
anything about a release date but
between the skulk stuff and the deep
dark there's a lot of things we could
possibly learn about during minecraft
live on october 16th
bungie revealed the patch notes for its
newest destiny 2 update which is the
first update to come out after the
launch of the season of the lost while
most of the update is dedicated to bug
fixes and tweaks the most high profile
improvement is the update in
cross-platform voice chat season of the
loss introduced crossplay in destiny 2
for the first time and this hotfix now
allows all of those players to actually
talk to each other however bungie notes
that voice chat on xbox still has some
issues to iron out specifically xbox
privacy settings and mute lists are
currently not functioning as intended
within destiny 2.
in addition the update tweaks a handful
of problems with weapons and armor it
solves an issue where stasis crystals
were doing more detonation damage
against players than intended which
could feel like a small nerf against
stasis abilities there is an extensive
list of all the patch notes over on
gamespot.com right now if you want to
check them out
ever since thq nordic mentioned the
return of this legendary franchise i've
been wondering what exactly it could be
so i want you to leave your best guess
and your wildest series in the comments
below and let's see who gets it right
thank you guys so much for watching and
we'll see you on your next gamespot news
update
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you